we had a mom when his brilliant belly
check book was published now he had I
get Iain O'Connor on after he sat down
with easily easily
my least favorite New York sports figure
of all time and James Dolan that's the
only way I could set up beam O'Connor of
ESPN how are you in
how are you rich I'm give voice to
everybody that you wrote about in this
feature hating James Dolan so tell me
tell me how dare you humanize him in in
this piece how dare you do that well I
don't know if I did I tried not to help
Jim Dolan I tried not to hurt him I just
wanted to reveal him and I'm not sure
that the Knicks fans who despised him
before itself any differently after it
I imagine you didn't know no I did I did
actually his comments on on battling his
alcoholism were something that
definitely resonated with me obviously I
did not know about his charitable
contributions in the area I assumed he
was charitable I assumed that the Knicks
are obviously part of the New York
fabric for as long as they are that they
would do that what what I the thing that
I I would I took away from his very
noble and worthy comments about his own
alcoholism and how he wouldn't blame it
on his family life or anybody else it
just seems that he never accepts
responsibility for anything that he's
done to run the Nixon to the ground
though he in yeah that's right that and
also on three different accused other
people of being alcoholics which is a
strange thing for a recovering alcoholic
to do and I actually did point that out
to him and what are you saying right
rich what do you say to that he didn't
he didn't have much of a response that
because I said listen if a fan yells out
of you what's happened hey sell the team
and he was walking to his car he stopped
and pivoted and he got in the guy's face
the guy and he braided the fan for
yelling that out I said you know as a
New Yorker I grew up in and around New
York City I can understand that but why
didn't you need to call the guy or
accuse the guy being an alcoholic and so
he said well you had a beer his hand and
but now he's done it on three different
occasions and I just think it's not
necessary and but he didn't have much to
respond to that and so as far as his
decisions running the Knicks he's not
really running them anymore that's one
thing I took away from
conversation is unlike say 1012 years
ago he really spend so little time on
the Knicks now he's so consumed by his
entertainment properties that he hires a
basketball executive he occasionally
checks in with that person now Steve
Mills and Scott Perry he provides the
resources and he goes to the games and
that's it otherwise he's worried about
building these entertainment venues in
Vegas and London and hopefully some
other cities and and that's where I
think he sees his legacy being
established over the next ten years I
think he's really retreating from the
whole public part of owning an NBA team
and and I thought that was actually an
important part of our conversation so do
you really think he is what what you
know you asked him about selling the
Knicks do you think he really is
thinking about it Ian I mean because I'm
sure that there's enough people that
could scrape together five billion if
that's what he wants although I think
the the price of the team took a hit
when you lose by 18 to the Suns after
your feature airs and is published do
you think he's really serious about it
the stock price actually went up
according to CNBC and then a story they
published in the hours after my piece
hit on ESPN yesterday morning and people
thought hey there's a possibility
Dolan's going to sell stock went up and
it was kind of a funny article to read
but I do think it's a feasible scenario
I don't think he's looking to sell but
he did tell me he could never not
consider selling because the answers to
his shareholders I do believe when you
look at rich two and a half years ago he
sold cable vision for nearly eighteen
billion dollars he's not afraid of doing
a major transaction that was a much
bigger sale than the proposed sale the
next four five billion I think if
somebody presented an offer over the
next three four five years in that range
or worth 1.5 billion more than the
valuation of the franchise according to
Forbes I think he would definitely
consider it no question about because he
doesn't like the public part of being an
owner of the necks even he told me after
they won their first game of the season
some fans actually called out some
positive things for him on his way out
of the building he didn't like that
either he doesn't like the fact that
when he goes out to dinner he needs a
security guard he doesn't like the fact
that when he's out shopping people yell
negative things at him sometimes he told
me he books
musical gigs with his band in Europe
just to get away so nobody can recognize
him that to me did not sound like a guy
who's eternally committed owning the New
York necks so I would not be surprised
overtime if that happens and I think
there are a lot of New York Knicks fans
who probably hope that that does indeed
happen I guess we'll see how it plays
out you know Connor interviewed James
Dolan for ESPN and ESPN comm here on the
Rich Eisen show and and him calling
somebody who heckles him in the streets
a drunk the thing that really upset me
about that is because it is a complete
lack of customer service it's a complete
disdain for it it is a complete disdain
for any sort of contact with a fan base
because he understands that he has the
crown jewel in many ways of a sports
franchise and folks are gonna come
regardless the number of celebrities
that I interview in who would have a
problem with him and would voice it if
they weren't afraid of some form of
retribution to their season tickets or
their front-row seat I've lost track of
it so that's part of what what does he
say about that when you have that
conversation with him about his
relationship with the fans he tells me
and he's told many people this that he
really cares deeply about the fans and
trying to win for them of course
his behavior in those instances would
would go cut against the grain of that
thought in that sentiment and I think I
do think this they've been bad for such
a long time they've won one playoff
series since Jeff Van Gundy walked out
of the building and quit 17 plus years
ago if the Knicks were a consistent
contender like basically his Rangers
have been for the most part I think the
way people look at him and his feisty
combative nature would be different but
the fact of the matter is he's been a
consistent loser in the NBA and
therefore his behavior is a big part of
the narrative why he might be considered
by most New Yorkers the worst owner in a
post Donald sterling NBA and and so his
response is I care deeply about hands
his friends and associates say there's
nobody I talk to every
from wayne gretzky the best CA to the
people who work for now the top levels
of the Rangers and they all say that
nobody cares more about trying to win
for the fans of this guy and his
resources that he provides proves that
well it's got to be beyond the resources
and it's the way you comport yourself
and in that context he has been a
failure without question and so I don't
think he has good answers to those
questions I think as Messier told me a
while back on the phone the only thing
that's going to change it for Jim is
winning if you don't win nothing else is
going to matter and of course they've
they've not found the right formula or
at least on the basketball side the
right executive to make that happen well
I don't if you don't mind me is jumping
in here Heon I mean just like I have to
I can't believe I'm gonna say this I
have to beg to differ with Mark Messier
because I'm sitting out here my kids are
wearing Celtics gear cuz my wife's a big
Boston fan I never thought my children
would ever wear that stuff I'm from
Staten Island ever thought that would be
in a million years and I don't want to
set foot in Madison Square Garden again
even if they do have 50 60 win seasons
because of what happened with Charles
Oakley and your conversation with him
your quote from him in this piece you
know Connor here on the Rich Eisen show
says to its quote he was out of control
he's talking about Charles Oakley when
he was dragged out of the garden by the
sea garden by Dolan's security at gar at
the garden on February 2017 he was out
of control anybody else who went even
half the way that he went would have
been ejected from the venue it just got
too bad he had to be taken out which to
me was the most outrageous part of the
piece because the fact that folks went
up to him to begin with is because Dolan
made him Oakley persona non grata at the
garden and not allowed to be in there
has he taken any responsibility at all
in your conversation for it that's an
outrage again that's an outrage I think
I think the bigger outrage at least the
way I look at it is not taking
accountability for the unica Brown
Sanders case in fact in that the verdict
was rendered back in 2007 and and I
think yes I agree with you on the Oakley
front and I said wasn't there anyway
here's a beloved Knick in your building
okay you
got an issue with him how about saying
he Charles come sit next to me for the
second half after we're gonna go back to
my office you and I are gonna talk
man-to-man we're going to settle our
differences
and you're gonna be a part of this
organization again and it just did me a
favor let's let's cool down let's let's
watch the rest of the game and then
we'll be in my office we need to be
after this game and he couldn't do that
because Oakley was too out of control I
talked to a lot of people who actually
are not enemies of Dolan who know him
very well and say that that should have
happened so many people in the building
say there was no way that that could
have happened that that Oakley was just
too belligerent in that moment sorry go
ahead
not the bigger cases really Browne
Sanders because if that case unfolded
today you imagine I just think it would
have been covered and looked at entirely
differently because back then it was
just kind of part of the garden culture
of dysfunction today with the and
rightfully so to me to movement I just
think that that would have been so much
worse for the Dolan for Isaiah Thomas
for everyone in MSG if they took that to
trial and lost and I think I I was
looking for more contrition for what
happened in that case instead the answer
was we were right that the jury got it
wrong I thought that was very
disappointing that so many years have
passed and he has not really taken any
accountability for the hostile work
environment that that created that case
to begin one yeah the the sexual
harassment suit that was filed against
the garden and Isaiah Thomas and and
James Dolan
look Ian last one for you why do you
think he did this I mean this is so out
of character to sit down with somebody
that's not in the local media and just
and and have a conversation why do you
think James Dolan did this well you know
rich I actually have covered the Knicks
over the years in the New York area
quite a bit as a columnist not as a beat
writer and I've actually written some
fairly critical piece is about Dolan and
so I was a little surprised that they
said yes to to my request I think he
just realized there were a lot of
outstanding issues and wanted to get his
side out and he bets people that
everyone so they vetted me I guess they
thought I was fair at least in my
criticism over the years
and I was a little surprised that I was
granted to sit down I didn't know how
long it would last I walked in not
knowing that I was a little concerned I
wouldn't get to he was gonna stand up
and walk out at some point and we had a
lot of ground to cover but he did sit
there for two hours and it was a
conversation it wasn't an inquisition
and but I pressed him on a lot of things
and I just think at some point he wanted
to get his side out on this host of
issues today and yesterday overtime and
and he did that so I didn't all I wanted
to do was inform people about the way he
thinks and why he made some of the
decisions that he made and then it was
up to the reader to decide whether or
not he or she still despised them didn't
despise them whatever I didn't want to
help him I didn't want to hurt him she
wanted to reveal and let the reader make
the decision on his or her own the last
one for you in your excellent book on
Bella check how do you think bill is
what do you think's happening in that in
that home base right now in in patriots
camp with two consecutive losses right
now we think what right it was probably
rich we Miami thing was such a fluke so
we wouldn't really probably have in this
conversation right if that didn't happen
but if it happened in Belichick had a
big role on that by putting Gronk on
field so I think they're probably still
okay relatively speaking if you look at
their postseason path it's still
manageable
I think Houston is going to lose to
Philadelphia this Sunday and all of a
sudden if the Patriots went out at home
against the bills of Jets which is very
likely they're the two seed and their
only road game and the playoffs will be
at Kansas City or perhaps at the
Chargers so I think they can still get
to the Super Bowl
they're the only franchise after
watching them this year that I would say
that about because I think Brady and
Belichick and Gronk and Edelman despite
their struggles this year relatively
they deserve the benefit of the doubt
and so I do think they're they're not
dead and buried though I would probably
say that about almost any other
franchise under the same set of
circumstances Ian thanks for the call
Bella check the making of a greatest
football coach of all times a perfect
holiday gift right now and
and thanks again I kind of feel like I
should put this conversation in for
reimbursement with NFL health care I
feel like this is some this has got to
be covered for therapy this conversation
we just had some we should thank you
thanks you bet thanks that's a you know
calm the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience